bonjour muriel hees temps boullier merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct d'alep à l'ap une ville qui est
très très durement touché par par cette
guerre presque dix ans de guerre en
syrie vous avez 19 ans vous êtes
étudiante
comment est ce que vous vivez
aujourd'hui après ces années compliquées
est toujours difficile d'ailleurs
bonjour je m'appelle mais réaliste un
boulier
je suis en deuxième monnaie de
biotechnologie à l'université d'alep
syrie
et bien malheureusement nous sommes
vraiment une génération sacrifiée
on a vécu depuis 2012 la guerre en syrie
et c'était vraiment très douloureux
il y avait toujours des bombardements on
a vécu pendant départ pour un
bombardement on allait à l'école et il
avait mené les les missiles et les
bombardements en dessus de nous c'était
vraiment un très très difficile parce
qu'on devait faire tourner tous en même
temps on devait on devait étudier on
devait aider nos parents c'était
vraiment très dur sur nous mêmes on
avait beaucoup d'amis qui mouraient à
cause de ces missiles on a perdu
beaucoup de proches et d'amis et c'était
vraiment très émouvant et très difficile
sur nos la guerre a commencé donc il y à
12 ans dans le sillage des printemps
arabes avec le le soulèvement de syriens
contre le gouvernement de bachar al
assad
quel regard vous portez vous aujourd'hui
sur ces événements sur ce soulèvement à
l'époque mois dernier personnellement
j'étais j'étais petit je ne comprenais
pas vraiment ce qui se passait mais
après on a vraiment vraiment vu que
c'est vraiment une guerre une vraie
guerre
mais quel avenir quel avenir vous voyez
muriel on parle beaucoup de problèmes
psychologiques aujourd'hui pour les
jeunes est ce que vous vous même vous
avez ces traumatismes en vous comment
est ce que vous voyez l'avenir de votre
pays aujourd'hui
ok maintenant ni un ni deux les jeunes
ne savent pas où est ce qu'ils vont
amener ce qui va se passer avec avec
parce que c'est vraiment ils veulent
il va sortir d'ici parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'avenir à en séries il veut ils veulent
avoir une belle vie
veulent ils veulent étudier ils veulent
savoir qu après qu après leurs études
ils vont faire quelque chose et je veux
laisser une trace
mais malheureusement dans notre pays je
ne pense pas qu'on peut vraiment faire
ceci parce que on a plus d'opportunités
tout est détruit moi il y avait ici une
année peut-être la biotechnologie je
croyais qu'il y avait quelque chose à
faire mais mick main ici en syrie je ne
pense pas que j'ai un avenir et si je ne
sais pas même pour les pour tous les
autres gens comme moi il y à la question
de l'embargo aussi un des des sanctions
contre la syrie comment est ce que
voulaient les percevez vous et la
jeunesse
syrienne en général e pour l'ambaq haut
il y avait beaucoup on a tous voulu
ainsi que l'école est que toutes ces
choses contre la syrie c'est ce même et
notre notre voie je pense je pense que
l'autre voie et 90e ne l'entend pas on
arrive pas on n'arrive pas à savoir que
faire ça complique le quotidien de votre
quotidien et ceux de votre famille c'est
en se
cet embargo imposé par les états unis et
également par l'union européenne
économiquement comment est ce que vous
vivez au jour le jour
comment est-ce que c'est compliqué de
trouver certaines choses de la vie
quotidienne
oui bien sûr maintenant tout est devenu
très cher le peuple et s'ils n'arrivent
plus à acheter
la moindre chose la nourriture est
vraiment devenu très cher
il ya des familles qui ne keane qui ne
mangent plus avant de dormir il ya des
enfants qui meurent de faim et tout est
devenu très cher maintenant et ce
dernier et on a on a perdu toute chose à
vivre et année les moindres les moindres
les moindres choses à vivre on est on
est en plus on est en train de chercher
et une seule opportunité de vivre mais
le peuple est en train de mourir de faim
même si la guerre est en train de finir
mais il ya la fin chi chi chi l'ha qui
les tue qui tuent le peuple est ce que
vous attendez qu'est ce que vous
attendez de de la communauté
internationale peut-être de la france en
particulier ce que vous avez un appel à
faire passer aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr il me rappelle est que
bien sûr ici tout le monde a besoin a
besoin a besoin d' aide
nous avons besoin que quelqu'un entende
notre voir que le peuple que le peuple
est en partie unités de vivre
il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui veulent
avoir une vie saine ce sens en conflit
sans peur voilà nous sommes en train de
vivre jour après jour on sait pas ce que
ce que domaine où on ne va pas les
chercher mais met en jeu sais pas si on
a compris en tout cas votre votre
messager et votre désarroi muriel merci
beaucoup de nous avoir livré votre
témoignage ce matin en direct sur arte
france